nos piden encontrar la raíz cuadrada de
100 déjame escribirlo por aquí en grande
el símbolo de raíz cuadrada es esta como
paloma extendida así que la raíz
cuadrada de 100 y cuando la ves indicada
así significa la raíz cuadrada positiva
si conoce los números negativos sabes
que también existe una raíz cuadrada
negativa pero este símbolo indica la
raíz cuadrada positiva veamos qué es lo
que nos indica esto esto nos indica
encuentra un número encuentra un número
positivo tal que si lo multiplicó por sí
mismo obtengo el número 7 entonces cuál
es el número que si lo multiplicó por si
mismo me da 100
veamos si multiplico 9 por sí mismo
obtengo 81 y si multiplico 10 por sí
mismo obtengo 100 así es que esto es
igual déjame escribirlo de esta manera
usualmente te puedes brincar este paso
pero ahora la raíz cuadrada de 100 la
voy a escribir como la raíz cuadrada de
10 por 10 y bueno sabemos que la raíz
cuadrada de algo multiplicado por sí
mismo va a ser ese algo así es que esto
va a ser simplemente 10 así es que la
raíz cuadrada de 100 es igual a 10
en la que creo que podrías establecer
este resultado es escribir que 10 al
cuadrado es igual a 10 por 10 y esto es
igual a 7